Let's get back to the phones at (617) 830-4715
the where do we want to go today? There are
so many people holding who want to talk. Let's
try our color from the eight, six, four area
code. Who's calling today from eight, six,
four. Hello? Yeah, that's you.
Hey, uh, I want you to get your opinion, David,
about, uh, how do you think that Nancy Polosi
is currently conducting the impeachment inquiry?
Right. Cause I have, uh, a couple of criticisms
that I'd like to mention. I just want to know
what your opinions are. Because you know,
recently a Nancy Pelosi, she just, uh, launched
the, uh, well he decided to formally launch
impeachment resolution. Right, right.
Yeah.
And so my problem with that is, is that it
feels like she's constantly making concessions
to, uh, the Republicans because I feel like
there was an equally valid reason on both
sides of the spectrum. Right. Because if she
had, she could've just thought with the, uh,
if the idea that there is no need for a due
process in the impeachment inquiry, right.
Cause it's not a criminal prosecution. Right.
And if she had just stuck with that, then
I feel like she would have, I feel like she
would've looked a lot stronger than now that
she's launching the a resolution because I
feel like she doesn't gain anything as she
was going to do. That should've done it from
the very beginning.
No. So here's the thing. I actually on this,
I disagree with you. I think there's lots
of fair criticisms of Nancy Pelosi. I think
that this is fine. Listen, there was a pre
impeachment inquiry phase during which witnesses
potential witnesses were being interviewed.
Trump was not involved in that. He alleged
he wasn't being given due process and that
it was unfair, but we are now at the, this
always happens, this happened in the Clinton
impeachment inquiry as well. Now they are,
they are formalizing the bounds of the inquiry.
The precedent is getting due process. I don't
at all think that it weakened Nancy Pelosi's
position to do that. And in fact, I think
that as Trump continues to say that it's unfair
and there's no due process, even though now
it's been outlined, I think it actually makes
Trump look worse and worse. So I think I'm
okay with the way Nancy Pelosi handled that
particular thing.
Okay. So let me ask you, what do you think
that, why do you think like, couldn't you
have just done that from the very beginning?
Right. Why do you think, what is the benefit
of going back and doing it now as opposed
to doing it at the beginning? Right. Because
now she's giving the, she's giving the right
end unison in order to, uh, say that, okay,
we were writing the entire time. It feels
like she's making a concession.
No, no, no. That's where I just disagree with
you. I listen you, it's normal that there's
a pre, there's a pre formalization phase and
then you formalize it. I don't think she's
giving the right anything. And again, I think
the right is going to be exposed as, as completely
not credible in their criticisms because they
will continue to say that they're not getting
due process. And that it's all unfair even
though now it's been formalized. So I'm not
here. Here's my concern about, there's two,
two concerns I have about impeachment. Number
one, are Democrats actually going to get any
of the Trump people to play ball with documents,
subpoenas or with showing up because if they
don't, then a lot of the, you know, the public
hearings that are supposed to be what convince
people that there's been a lot of wrongdoing
aren't going to be effective. That's concern
number one. And then concern number two. I've
seen arguments on both sides, but I'm concerned
about how the scope is of the impeachment
inquiry. I would like it, I would like it
to be wider, but there's conflicting. Yeah.
Yes. That was the next thing I was going to
mention. Yeah, yeah, that's the next thing
I was going to mention. So, so I think the,
we're on the same page at least in regards
to that, that, you know, narrowing down this
impeachment inquiry, right. To just the a
Ukraine transcript and you know, the potential
quick quote pro between the Trump administration
and uh, and Ukraine is, I mean, this is, do
you, do you agree to at least that much is
maybe a not great political tactics?
Yes, yes. I don't think we needed to include,
you know, there's people who are saying, Oh,
they should have done the Russia collusion.
And it's like, no, no, no. Listen that, that,
that's pretty toxic at this point. And I actually
think it's the right reason. It's the right
decision not to include that, but financial
crimes, Yemen, I mean, there's much more that
could be part of this that's not, and I do
think that that is a bit concerning, but I've
read some pretty good pieces that say it's
the right decision to narrow it. We'll see
how it plays out. Right. I mean, in the end
we'll, we'll just have to wait and see. Listen,
it sounds like you're crinkling paper on,
onto your headset. Your, your, your hand says,
so I'm going to let you go, but I really appreciate
the call.
Okay. Yeah. All right. Take care. Thanks,
David. I appreciate
G. O. And. A. There we go.